My feeling was that this was the most promising.
I couldn't figure out how to fill in one digit at a time and make that work,
because if we had something like the word EVEN, and we fill in 1 digit,
and we have, say, 8V8N, I didn't figure out how to make sense of that.
We have this mixture of some letters that are filled in and some that aren't.
That didn't work for me.
This approach, one big formula--yes,
we could figure out a way to make one big formula,
but the problem is I don't think that would be any faster,
because it would take eval a long time because it would be a very long formula.
This approach I think is the most promising, so let's talk about it.